hi I'm Greg Gutfeld with Jedediah Vila
Juan Williams Jesse waters and a cigar
band is her Sun Visor Dana Perino the
five
[Music]
we're now into the fourth year of the
Democrats election tantrum that would be
old enough for kindergarten but maturity
matters more than years so they'll never
get in and they've learned from the best
the media I have to say I found his
answers total gobbledygook about that I
mean you know the fact is Muller wrote a
letter of protest in William bar we have
a staunch Trump ally who is also a
skilled bureaucrat and who's smarter
than Donald Trump
that makes him scarier on both those
measures if your theory on Barr is
correct
where did he become radicalized if we
can't trust you all to tell us then I
sort of feel like there maybe there's a
coup happening there guests lighting gas
lighting not exactly rational analysis
but going to the view for political
insight it's like going to the zoo for
an oil change or Hillary for legal
expertise he is the president's defense
lawyer he is not the Attorney General of
the United States in the way that he has
conducted himself now calling for his
resignation makes perfect sense because
he's not discharging the duties of the
office oh please imagine getting legal
advice from Hillary that's like getting
driving tips from bado or facts from
these showboating hacks he testified
falsely deliberately and falsely his
credibility was shredded yesterday I
think he should resign he's burned
through any credibility he had in that
role and he should resign mm-hmm it's
like they all took the same drug now
unless you can claim them as dependents
you don't need these people why they lie
to your face they tell you what's in the
report isn't really there but it is in
case you forgot and the media is hoping
you did the report is public sorry guys
it's all in there if there were any
crimes we'd know and guess what we do
the evidence is now that the president
was falsely accused of colluding with
the Russians and we concluded that the
evidence developed during the special
counsels investigation was not
sufficient to establish that the
president committed an obstruction of
justice offense hmm
one wonders what kind of bozos
relitigate what's over and done with he
is actually as dangerous in the position
of attorney general as Donald Trump is
as president the United States bar is
not an Attorney General of the United
States he is Donald Trump's my friends
attorney he's his Lackey Lackey so the
Democratic media complex held a hearing
to complain about getting dumped at the
prom
it's not about collusion it's about not
getting what they wanted from the report
like they didn't get what they wanted
from the election in retaliation they
wasted your time your money to throw a
public tantrum fully embraced by a
bedwetting media that hates you and
hates themselves after all who else
would choose to relive their failures
every day but a group of self-loathing
saps they relived November 8th 2016
every day just to make a buck it's it's
not Groundhog Day
cuz that's a funny movie it's it's the
Titanic and they're the boat guess who
that orange iceberg was alright Jesse I
have an analogy know what it granted
okay thank you know what this is like
for me working at FNC and not caring
about this story it's like being at ESPN
and being forced to cover the homerun
Derby
because it's meaningless and it's all
show it doesn't have any effect on the
overall standings that's how I feel
about this I'll give you another sports
analogy it's like losing a playoff game
and pretending you won yeah they lost so
badly yesterday and the media is acting
like this was a big victory but you know
they didn't win because they're so angry
and they're so threatened if you listen
to that listen to what happened they've
lost control of the narrative and
they've lost control of the process as
well and it's driving them crazy because
the full reports out and there are no
more indictment so essentially the witch
hunts over but they haven't gotten the
memo yet yeah it is very interesting to
hear them accuse someone else of lying
after two years of lying and not
apologizing they have literally no
self-awareness whatsoever but here is
why bar is so threatening bar outlawed
Muller and Wiseman on the obscure of
destruction statute that they were
trying to footsie with remember they
didn't charge them they just floated
this legal theory that was totally
untested and the Department of Justice
had never used before so he basically
ended the cou secondly they're not used
to having such a seasoned pro in the
department under Donald Trump they had
sessions didn't really have the
firepower to compete they had Rosen
Stein who wasn't really there he kind of
abdicated his role so you have someone
come in clean up shop and then really
unflappable II and deftly explain what
happened with the Muller report and the
Democrats are driving they've been
driven crazy because they can't compete
rhetorically with them and then thirdly
they're panicking because they know that
bar is investigating the investigators
they're looking at they're looking at
the the FISA abuse they're looking at
the human intelligence assets that they
ran the unmasking and the criminal leaks
and they'd ever thought this would be
meringue on them and it has and they're
really nervous you know i dana think
about all this energy they're devoting
to this that could be spent on getting
elected getting a new president maybe or
maybe concentrating on the important
issues that matter to all americans like
myself Karl Rove Rose calm today saying
well the Democrats be able to resist
impeachment but I think they've kind of
already started yeah and if you look at
the Democrats polling at like 70 percent
that they want impeachment but who
doesn't want impeachment on the
Democratic side are the most of the
candidates that there's now 20 on the
Democratic side but they're all going to
have to compete for attention against an
impeachment push so you're not gonna be
able to talk about your student loan
debt free plan or your climate change
plan or whatever else you have up your
sleeve because the headlines will all be
about impeachment I also think what's
frustrating to me is that they seem to
be asking Barr to make a decision that
Muller wasn't willing to make himself
right why in the world would they think
that that would be possible that doesn't
make sense to me the last thing I would
say is I can't stand resign politics you
resign no you resign nobody's resigning
ya over any of this nobody yeah but it's
an election to be held with that
spotlight politics you get that you get
on TV when you shave
should resign exactly exactly that's
what this is about call on anyone to
resign I don't believe I think you
called on me to resign yes you know on
in the green room you were just saying
to me how upset you were how the
Democrats were calves annoying bar I
just think this is you know like you
said yes that you didn't watch you know
I think there are lots of people who
didn't read apparently including the
Attorney General who says he didn't
really look at any of the evidence
before he decided there was no
obstruction secondly here's a guy who
says oh I didn't know anything about
mower having any objections
two weeks after Muller sent him a letter
saying I object that this is not the
full story that you've put out and it
leads to a lack of public trust and then
you guys can mine say oh yeah this is
just the Democrats having a tantrum let
me just say this to you I didn't hear
this when Congress was having oversight
hearings on Benghazi for the 15th time
oh no then Congress was fulfilling its
constitutional rule which is to act as
an equal partner under the Constitution
to the executive and to employ its
resources subpoenas on the like to get
answers for the American people it's the
house of the people but now Donald Trump
is fighting every subpoena obviously we
don't have a date for robert muller to
testify we don't know if Don McGann can
testify hmm it's something being hidden
and when Kamala Harris says to this
Attorney General
Oh mr. Attorney General what is going on
were you informed by robert muller of
objective ah well I don't know what do
you mean how about this do you have a
record of conversations with Robert mow
well yeah I was taking notes but well
can we have it up no most ridiculous I'm
it's unbelievable right response you
want outrage recruits should decide
whether they trust Muller or not you
have to make up your mind because
suddenly it's okay you trust Muller you
wait for the report to come out now all
of a sudden it's oh we don't trust
Muller so we need bards who have
reviewed every ounce of evidence that
was what Muller was there for to look at
all the evidence and now everyone's
complaining all Democrats are saying oh
well we have a problem with the timing
of how much was released by
and when the whole report is out guess
what you don't like Bar fine you don't
like Trump fine the reporters out there
was still no conspiracy with the
Russians there was still no crime there
was still no legitimate case to bring up
an obstruction charge that's the reality
so instead of worrying about who did
what or who read what this is the report
this is where it stands if we were all
of sane minds we would have already
moved on from this story to something
else I think that's the that's the
message I'm getting at the oh you guys
say it's over let's move ignore it's not
over it's not is not but just to
reiterate it's not collusions conspiracy
and the Trump campaign was receptive and
understood they were to benefit from
this right